les investissements et les l'intranet à
monsieur vincent le dos monsieur le
président la question s'adresse à madame
la ministre de l'éducation nationale
madame la ministre
le gouvernement auquel vous appartenez
sonne la fin de l'idée socialiste qui
n'est plus qu'une étiquette politique
sans contenu doctrinal d'en comprendre
le malheur français
l'historien philosophe marcel gauchet en
conclut je cite dans ces conditions ils
restent en lice la gauche morale qui
compense son vide intellectuel par la
virulence de ces postures dénonciatrice
et la gauche électorale qui s'occupe des
affaires sérieuses c'est à dire la
conquête du pouvoir et les carrières
politiques la gauche électorale nous
l'avons entendu hier à la radio ça va
mieux qu'il disait la gauche morale ici
même lorsque pour masquer la confusion
née de la sphère black m
le premier ministre distribue les
mauvais points à cette droite qui a
l'outrecuidance de faire primer la
morale républicaine sur la création
artistique la gauche morale c'est aussi
vous madame la ministre qui osaient
ressortir des vieux concept pour reposer
la france des curés à celle des
instituteurs au nom de valeurs
républicaines qui sont pourtant aussi
bien défendu dans le privé que dans le
public
c'est ainsi près de la moitié des
établissements scolaires primaires et
secondaires de ma circonscription que
vous avez blessés nous ne sommes plus en
1984 madame la ministre
mais nous sommes toujours prêts à
marcher sur la bastille pour défendre
l'éducation nationale dans toutes ses
composantes
ainsi quand dans le nord d'une
différence de traitement frappe le privé
dans les moyens dédiés aux classes
bilangues suite rats votre réforme du
collège gauche morale gauche électorale
il vous reste moins d'un an pour
répondre aux vraies questions posées par
notre système éducatif qui ne va pas
mieux
puissiez vous apporter de vraies
réponses là où trop souvent vous en
appelez au bilan deux prédécesseurs
pourtant vous n'êtes pas au gouvernement
pour faire oeuvre d'historien impartiale
des biens plutôt pour agir
quid du bilan sur les nouveaux rythmes
scolaires quid des actions vous allez
mener pour lever les angoisses qui
étrenne la chaîne éducative parents
enseignants élus de la maternelle à
l'université
ça ne va pas mieux madame la ministre et
les représentants des nations attendent
de vous
non des postures mais des engagements
clairs et précis la parole est à madame
najat vallaud belkacem miniser éducation
nationale de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député le doubs comment vous
dire les choses en fait je vais vous
dire je rêve d'un débat qui serait un
débat serein et de bonne foi sur les
politiques éducatives mais vraiment j'en
rêve
je rêve d'un débat dans lequel nous
aurions des objectifs simples comme un
des analyses sérieuses objective et
longtemps je crois j'ai tenté de vous
entraîner sur ce terrain là considérant
que l'éducation devait dépasser les
clivages partisans
force m'est de constater qu'à ce terrain
là vous avez préféré les outrances la
caricature les contre-vérités force
m'est de constater que vous n'aurez
jamais fait depuis 2012 le moindre début
de commencement de mea culpa pour le
sacrifice véritable de l'école publique
qui a été réalisée pendant l'ancien
quinquennat alors monsieur le député ne
vous étonnez pas que je vous renvoie
sans cesse à cette faute originelle
ne vous étonnez pas que je ne vous
estime pas les mieux placés au monde
pour donner des leçons de politique
éducative à ce gouvernement qui agit
depuis 2012 pour faire de l'école sa
priorité
ne vous étonnez pas puisque visiblement
la réussite de nos élèves et l'égalité
d'accès à la réussite de nos élèves ne
vous intéresse pas ne vous étonnez pas
que je ne consacre pas plus de temps que
cela répondra à vos questions et que je
mets toute mon énergie à agir mais